They jumped her Catalan,
their goods,
which they had gotten in the land of Canaan and came into Egypt,
Jacob and all his seed with them.
And he sent Judah before month Joseph to direct his face under gosh.
And,
and they came into the land of Goshen and Joseph Made ready his chariot and went
to meet Israel,
his father,
and presented himself to them and fell on his neck and wept on his neck a good
while.
And Israel said,
I can now die because I've seen your face because you're still alive.
And Pharaoh spake unto Joseph saying that father and thy brethren are coming to
the,
and the land of Egypt is before the and the best of the land.
Your father and brothers can dwell in the land of Gosh and let them dwell.
And if they're now no any men of activity among them,
then make them rulers over my cattle.
It gives them a job.
And Joseph brought in Jacob,
his father and said,
and before Pharaoh and Jacob Blessed Pharaoh.
That's a very interesting little turn of events because you'd expect the
opposite under those circumstances.
So
it appears that Jacob was a man of relatively great self possession.
Cause that's not an,
you wouldn't bless Queen Elizabeth in all likelihood as you had a lot of gall.
And Pharaoh said unto Jacob,
how old are you?
And Jacob said,
I'm 130 years,
few and evil have been the days of the years of my life and I've not attained
unto the days of the years of my,
of my,
of the life of my fathers and the days of their pilgrimage.
And Jacob Blessed Pharaoh and went out from before Pharaoh and Israel dwelt in
the land of Egypt,
in the country of Gosh,
and,
and grew and multiplied exceedingly.
And Jacob lived in the land of Egypt,
17 years.
So the whole age of Jacob was 147 years.
And the time drew nigh that Israel must die.
And he called his son.
Joseph had said unto him,
if I have now found grace in thy sight,
put,
I pray thee thy hand under my thigh and deal kindly and truly with me,
bury me.
Not,
I pray thee in Egypt,
but I will lie with my fathers now shall carry me out of Egypt and burry me and
they're burying place.
And Joseph said,
I will do as you've said.
And it came to pass after these things that one told Joseph,
behold I father is sick.
And he took with him his two sons,
Madison FM and one told Jacob and said,
behold thy son.
And one told Jacob and said,
behold thy son,
Joseph Cometh unto Thee and Israel strength in himself and sat upon the bed.
And Israel said unto Joseph,
I had not thought to see your face and low God has also showed me your children.
And Joseph brought them out from between his knees and out himself with his face
to the earth.
And Joseph took them both and for him in his right hand towards Israel's
lefthand and Madison,
his lefthand toward Israel's right hand and brought them near unto him.
And Israel stretched out his right hand and laid it upon firms head who was the
younger and his left hand upon Madison's head guiding his hands purposefully for
Madison was the first board.
And when Joseph saw that his father laid his right hand on the head of the frame
and displeased him and he held up as far as hand to remove it from informs head
onto [inaudible] head.
And Joseph said unto his father,
not,
not.
So my father for this is the first board put the right hand upon his head head
and his father refused and said,
I know what my son,
I know it.
He shall also become a people and he shall also be great,
but truly his younger brother shall be greater than he and his seed shall become
a multitude of nations.
Another repeat of the same thing that happens continually.
It's is when,
when God wants to intervene in human affairs,
what he does is invert tradition.
It's something like that.
And so that's a sign that that there's something new and special going on and
that gives precedents to the younger child rather than the older child
precedents to what is new rather than what's traditional.
Of course,
sometimes that's necessary because tradition is insufficient and sometimes
something new has to come into being in order to update it.
And Jacob called together his sons and said,
gathered together so that I can tell you that which shall be follow you in the
last days.
Gather yourself together and here you sons of Jacob and hearken unto Israel,
your father,
Ruben.
I'm not going to go through all 12 of these Reuben,
thou art,
my firstborn,
my might,
and the beginning of my strength,
the Excellency of Dignity and the Excellency of power.
Now
the story's quite interesting here because Jacob Blesses Joseph's sons before he
blesses it's old science.
And so what he's doing is placing the rights of the first born into the sons of
his favorite son,
and then he goes to his sons.
And so that has implications for the way the biblical stories laid themselves
out from thence forward
the excellence of dignity in the Excellency of power,
unstable as water.
Thou shalt not excel because that went up to thy father's bed,
then defiled it.
He went up to my couch.
You may remember that Ruben slept with his fathers,
cucumber,
concubine,
Simeon and Levi are brethren.
Instruments of cruelty are in their habitations.
That painting there.
What happened with Simeon and Levi was that somebody lay with their sister Dinah
and then offered to marry her and then had and then he came circumcised because
that was part of the deal and then how to older men circumcised and then Simeon
and Levi went in when they were recovering and killed them all and then Jacob
and all his people had to leave because all that irritated their relatives.
So
see me,
Simeon and Levi are brethren the instruments of cruelty or in their habitations.
All my soul come out into their secret unto their assembly,
mine on or be not thou United for in their anger they slew a man and in their
self self will they dig down a wall,
curse be their anger.
For it was fierce and their route for it was cruel.
I will divide them in Jacob and scattered them in Israel,
Judah,
thou art.
He who my brother and shall praise I hand shall be in the neck of dynamics that
I father's children shall bow down before the Judah is alliance welp from the
prey.
My son though art gone up,
he stooped down.
He couched as a lion and as an old lion who shall rose him up.
The sceptre shall not depart from Judah,
nor a law giver from between his feet until Shiloh camp and unto him shall the
gathering of the people be.
Joseph is a fruitful bough,
even a fruitful bough by a well whose branches run over the wall.
The archers have sorely grieved him and shot at him and hated him,
but his bow abode in strength and the arms of his hands were made strong by the
hands of the mighty God of Jacob.
For then since the shepherd,
the stone of Israel,
even by the god of my father,
who she'll help the and by the Almighty who shall bless thee with the blessings
of heavens above blessings of the deep that Liat under blessings of the beasts,
breasts,
and of the womb.
The blessings of thy father have prevailed above the blessings of my progenitors
unto the utmost bound of the everlasting hills.
They shall be on the head of Joseph and on the crown of the head of him that was
separate from his brother and all these are the 12 tribes of Israel,
and this is it.
That they're farther spake unto them and blessed them.
Everyone according to his blessing,
he blessed them.